viewer discretion is advised eminent
cops is filmed on location with the
brave strong women of law enforcement
all suspects are innocent until proven
guilty in a court of law I'm gonna say
we're gonna be fine
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the late to the party hey
wish you were doing his job instead of
putting up signs hey leave me in video
studio is always a scare who is not gay
follow him on Twitter at not gay Jerrod
me at s Crowder with your thoughts your
comments your photo shops your videos
after family obligations during
collisions Jared be good I'm good enough
at G Morgan Jr Jarrell is here hey
Gerald what's the wine of the day stag
Len booth bellick's Cabernet so we have
a lot to get to in Blair why does a
guest today we have Alex Epstein why
[ __ ] in the military and we also
have in commute truth coming out too
and give me a truth the secret I hate
this is a rough week we will get to a
little bit down the line here rights
versus commodities in the wake of the
health care this is vice president Mike
Pence bro those are some names right
early synonyms what right yeah one hint
that's not a right and that we'd love
for you to send along what you think
should be a right versus what is okay I
think it through just the intro sorry
all right
okay a lot has happened this week go
watch the show if you're not a mug club
member
otherwise you're cheap bastard but
everyone is still talking about
President Trump reversed the Obama
decision on transgenders in the military
so of course everyone is outraged about
this course well did you we'll talk
about it with Blair white you just came
he just tweeted it out I think he caught
some people by surprise with what he
just tweeted it out be the best idea
okay Jared no opinions no opinions I
just don't understand why he has
announced everything on Twitter I feel
like he he's kind of like overstepped
possibly the purpose tour I get I get
the idea of bypassing media but like
yeah some things maybe could use like a
formal letter yeah somebody needs a
second draft yeah hey listen there's
there's a lot too I understand that
there are different sides to this issue
it's not just an issue that requires one
blanket statement all right especially
but I convention when you're dealing
with the suicide rate when you are
dealing with the issues that obviously
played the transgender community you can
get into the nature-nurture argument but
they won't be allowed in the United
States military in other news the ISIS
suicide bombing Brigade wants you to
know that they're open-minded and hiring
there's a place to go some real dark
humor starts Asha mystic joke right off
yeah real sight is suicide Blair's gonna
be thrilled
ah now I realize our our we'll talk
about this next week more spend computer
one of our interns talk about this in
Germany they're actually there's
affirmative action effectively in the
military for more sexual diversity among
the truth in their hiring they also also
they're hiring more disabled people
they're going out of their way to find
more Christian this is the issue when
you deal with the identity politics that
becomes a problem the slippery slope
argument a perfectly valid argument and
this doesn't really come as a surprise
though if you've been following the
rhetoric the heated rhetoric Germany's
newest Fuhrer great citizens of Germany
as our country rises like a phoenix from
the ashes we should be a lesson to all
of Europe as we cut into our own of the
new nation baby maybe he can is his
price
go get your father
well I shouldn't have been surprised
please you see the cup in hindsight send
in Jerry's now face a boycott well the
threat of a boycott
I love how now that's how lazy we've got
yeah yeah rather than do something we're
just gonna do a boycott yell at you and
then when people didn't want to do a
boycott because they like things can I
do a buy cod and now they're threatening
boycotts but they're threatening that
interiors with a boycott because a new
study uncovered that a major ingredient
in herbicide weed killers was a 9 out of
10 of their ice cream so what it was
below epa levels i guess which makes you
wonder what the epa levels are yeah well
I don't really care if it still tastes
good that's not gonna kill me I'm good
it's still don't you like an ice cream
but I make an exception for going I will
tell you what yeah we'll never do the
been enjoy the Jerry's boycott no that's
one of those things I might listen I
can't go with you their target I can
they kick out salvation or Oceana yeah
so I can get that stuff at Walmart but
there's just only one place to get ice
cream and that is Evan and if you try
and say Brahms No
so this is Bluebell they've been on the
question though 4G yeah yeah you want
some Listeria I think the lesser of two
evils I'll take they cancel each other
out you blend them together it's great
I'll take GMOs over just death it's like
that it's like the Angel of Death
that's what Listeria is is horrible like
three times with Bluebell yeah well just
get a letter from those lawyers all
right so this has been accusations for a
long time I've been injuries with the
GMOs this isn't a first time for a four
kind of a granola company and the test
is the tests were actually prompted a
lot of you won't realize this of the
products upon the release of a few new
flavors which looking back could have
been suspicious Monsanto mania and run
DDT it almost seems like a canary in the
coal mine yeah you know that's bad
marketing sometimes you got to really
just check the labels on the shelf folks
skullcap from Walmart again birds eggs
so okay we're going to talk with Blair
wide about the transgender issue in the
military this is something that I think
is important that ties in because what
we're talking about today was trans
dinners in the military is not at all
the same conversation that we had
yesterday or tomorrow the changing rule
a perfect example is this was on the
view one of their home hey this segment
and LGBTQA a IP panel to prove how
beautiful and how how how we should all
be open-minded to the developing
community and that these these folks are
people too it's the opposite of that
roll the clip I mean when I first came
out to my mom I came out to her as a
lesbian originally when I was like in
11th grade and then she knew that I was
pansexual and then she was like oh so
you can be with men then and I'm like
yeah but I don't like men romantically
so like sorry mom disappointing your
mother but you can't leave but does that
mean just men sexually yeah okay so look
at this guy's we understand pansexual
homoromantic first of all do you uh now
do all pansexual homo-romantic do you
all understand this here's the part
where they all lie right but I don't
like men romantically you're a user this
is a great this is horrible can you
imagine some guy said you know I just
like yeah I like [ __ ] for sex yeah
that's about it you become a pig and you
never get a job again this is a horrible
it's a horrible human being and this is
the this is the kind of hypocrisy that
we allow to slip by it would be the most
horrifying statement on television would
have millions of plays on YouTube if the
guy just flat out so it would be
hilarious but I mean I just went out
said I don't like women for sex J I
don't want to buy them flowers or dinner
I just want to have sex with him but
they're like oh different kinds of love
and here's the deal people say are you
picking on the fat land whales well
listen I know we're supposed to feel bad
for her here because she's she's fat and
she's ugly right but first of half of
those are choices but here's the deal
they were maybe bullied at some point I
understand that but we are not bullying
people when they are trying to determine
exactly how we can speak and what we can
think that's the point to this panel
guess what we're no longer bullying when
you just got done objectifying men
saying that they were nothing more than
a hump stick you're a bad person also
here's something else that I find funny
when I think of discrimination or
prejudice I think of the world that
doesn't understand people and judges but
what I wouldn't understand any do judge
harshest critics these identities and
and pronouns are the lgbtq+ inaccurate
statement most definitely
now it's funnies we used to be accused
of straw Manning when we'd write down
LGBTQA AIP
and then we just staring lgbtq+ yeah as
poss 3/5 RT slightly negative Cylons EU
somewhere in there so we were accused of
strong enemy even here it has become so
wide the umbrella term uses LGBTQA IP
there's LGBTQ AI peak you can mean queer
there's sometimes there's two Q's
because it made queer and questioning
I've seen it a multitude of different
way though I'm not making it up asexual
intersex asexual asexual intersex allies
queer or questioning depending pansexual
it is exhausting these no these are all
in stand I hear you even just see them
trying to cover themselves listen I know
some people out there you always get
some smart s in the comments section
don't keep commenting I want to see your
comments below if you think if you think
this is as important as I do because a
lot of people say well look we're
talking about a budget there's a budget
to about to be passed and you're talking
about case you know why because this is
a fundamental attempt at a retransfer
Meishan of society this in tandem with
ABC NBC CBS every single mainstream
newspaper take late night Samantha P
Trevor Noah Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Fallon
co-owner of every single person when
they're trying to push this agenda which
completely breaks down the barriers of
biology and even yeah heteronormative
tradition which has been the bedrock of
society since the beginning of time I
think it's important I think culture is
upstream from politics and that's why
we're talking about it here's something
else funny when you're queer it's almost
becomes like a second major to spot like
okay who is safe and I see other
feminine people with shaved heads we
immediately make I know exactly what is
obviously I'm not you if anything
happens
right behind you I call it a your guess
is as good as mines intuition no
sweetheart when somebody else is walking
down the street with purple lipstick
looks like the girlfriend from American
History X that's not second nature
that's just using your eyes I know you I
got you a hon second aren't you what do
you mean you're right behind it we're
gonna be right with it if they're a man
right behind them with a strap-on to peg
them because that's what all they're
good for this is a bad person this is a
person who happens to be ugly and fat so
you want to feel bad for them this is a
bad person who uses people also has very
little to offer intellectually you need
to understand what into it what is
second that was a sense a sense 6/10
second I don't know what it is anyway so
if I told you I was a bisexual would
that change something for you I'd want a
negative HIV test first I am very open
to a woman who says she's bisexual I'm
like oh I get it
when a man says that I'm like so you're
gay I know it's a double standard I
don't know why my brain bag this all
comes back to toxic masculinity yes very
masculine very aggressive and this is
why it matters it's blame it on toxic
masculinity which is a huge irony
because the left likes to blitt let this
includes feminists LGBTQ AIP social
justice worries and the mainstream
platform including Bernie Sanders and
Hillary Clinton of the DNC they blame
things on toxic masculinity while
perpetually trying to make men out to be
toxic thing demonize meant you know
toxic masculinity what do they mean by
that we'll do a whole I think in-depth
video because what they we expect men to
be masculine yes we expect them to be
aggressive no that's incorrect
but when people like this for perpetual
victims see any kind of man who is
authoritative a man who knows what he
wants a man who is able to make
decisions a man who can leave they see
that as aggressive well we need to find
words like aggressive and they just file
that all under toxic masculinity by know
if you want to but there's one aspect of
masculine society it's probably become
toxic
it's the pickup culture of twitting what
evil tweeting them and sometimes
teaching teaching women and treating
women there that was the word I was
looking for as Anthony Weiner he's
tweeting women but treating women as
though they're nothing more than sex sex
objects which is what little mrs.
American history is purple lipstick yeah
out she's the only toxically masculine
archetype which is the irony of the
entire panel
all right Sonia but they go back to the
view we'll talk about this with Blair
why - those are perfect date they go
back to the the view on the on the what
do you call one location this was their
package gonna do a panel and this is the
part of the show where the black
progressive hosts realize that they're
not as progressive as they thought they
were and they're very confused I'm very
confused
I don't understand the woman that said I
know not a woman he actually doesn't
identify with a gender well you just
said - chief oh yeah I got your back you
psychopath but she talked about men and
women in real terms no that's only she
can explain your sexual
[Laughter]
there's no way she is trying to be the
most holic listen I got she literally
looks it goes from hey hey virtue signal
to hey no it's not she it's they because
she doesn't like to be called this using
she and then goes I got your back then
someone else says no she apologizes
you know appalled oh my gosh I did I'm
just I said I but I meant to say they
he's like you're Simon Says away from
hell some point is just hey now what are
your preferred gender pronouns okay you
changed it eight times within a city was
in a span of this video package it
wasn't even to show that was of you it
was the video package they changed their
opinions and what they want to be called
and they want this is why it's okay to
make fun of them it doesn't matter how
unattractive they are doesn't matter how
much they were bullied to because at
some point we all become adults and now
they want to bully everyone that was
bullying right there yeah you can't sit
if you have to say that it's worse from
there and you wonder why we have a
problem with this really did you look
like a guy I'm calling you a guy if you
look like a girl calling your girl deal
with it sorry it's not even if we don't
simplify it that much it is so
exhausting did you picture this of the
battlefront line sir no SEAL Team six
all right
he has a clear shot I prefer Z all right
sorry what does Z means gender-neutral
an bin Laden got away take him out how
do you know he identifies as a he and
this is the thing it's ever-changing
language and it is used as the ultimate
bully pulpit and all great though you
know authoritarian regimes have done
that throughout history I'm not
comparing Little Miss American History X
Redux there to Hitler I'm not what I'm
saying is that every authoritarian
regime has used language yes first and
foremost is its most effective political
weapon yeah and that's why I wanted to
do this segment because in the wake of
the the healthcare the desktop see
that's this week with with pence coming
in with 51 to 50 and there's some faced
emotion kill the bill
as this was down in the Senate floor
people came in and screamed out kill the
bill don't kill us and this is again why
language matters so much so let me ask
you this since you guys aren't you have
seem to have two syllable phrases today
what uh what Your Honor oh man what does
that mean it mean when someone says
don't kill us what is that assume that
assumes that the bills if it goes
through it's gonna kill them what it
means is that someone is responsible for
how is someone responsible for killing
you it must mean they are proactively
taking an action to kill oh you want to
be essentially so it assumes yes it
assumes that health care paid for by
other people is a right and this is
what's so ironic the left doesn't care
about the rights of people who were
paying for their own health care
beforehand they only care about the
other big giant voting block of non
contributors who weren't paying for
health care - a cancer survivor needs
about what my dad's a cancer survivor
he actually would he couldn't afford his
health care he needs
not Obamacare he needs the opposite of
that so when we say you're killing me
because you're not creating legislation
or maintaining legislation that favors
me it assumes what like Bernie Sanders
always says that it's a human right
health care so I think it's an important
distinction to make and this is why the
left cannot come to agreements this is
where we can't find common ground we
can't see eye to eye if we're not even
starting with the same premise as to
what a right is and we'll go through a
few examples and I would like to see
your comments here on youtube or send us
a tweet at us Crowder at at knock' Jared
with what you think are actual rights
versus commodities understanding the
difference so what is a right let's
define this first it's a just claim or
title whether legal prescriptive or
moral according to dictionary.com now in
the USA the beauty of that is it's
prescribed by the Constitution so we say
well how is it legal prescriptive so it
can be different but human rights
they're based in natural rights in the
USA they're prescribed clearly in the
Constitution okay
what's a commodity now to clarify
nothing bill to a commodity tends to be
a raw sort of resource like iron or gold
we're using a broader definition here
the economic commodities okay economic
commodities and services in economics a
commodity is a marketable item produced
to satisfy wants or needs
can comprised of either goods or
services all right marlis ed to begin
with pretty good understand it so this
is where I think we have some
disconnects let's go through some
examples of things that people assume
are rights human right to healthcare
healthcare okay what's your right you
have the right to take any legal
measures you deem necessary to ensure
your own personal health that includes
access ability to purchase services of
your choosing no one should be able to
impede you from seeking the healthiest
life possible there you go let's see
what's a commodity well a drug a
treatment or services created at the
risk or investment of a business owner
like health insurance programs based on
the concept of an aggregated risk pool
balance with offsetting costs and
premiums or deductibles the average
annual cost of health care is about ten
thousand I think some like ten thousand
something dollars another statin from me
that's a commodity hey I have a right to
health sure you have a right to be
healthy I have a right to your advil no
you know you have to pay for Advil why
because someone paid to create that
Advil
that's a commodity we need to understand
what rights actually guarantee and
there's a fundamental difference and
we'll get to some of the rights that
conservatives fight for in a bit but
education that's declared a right often
from the left okay what's your right
sure you have a right to educate
yourself I think we can all agree on
that
to learn to be unabated in pursuing your
higher education thereof or your
personal education that's your right but
what would be a commodity a degree maybe
from a university whose cost is
determined based on a quality of
teaching track records of graduate their
viability is the flexibility of the
services officer offered by the school
the average annual cost to in public
state colleges some around twenty five
thousand I think a private college is
close to fifty thousand so again that
costs somebody something yeah it costs
the professor he had to get a degree he
had to get training to become highly
specialized to teach at Harvard you do
not have it you have a right to educate
yourself go to the library read on the
internet use Bing if you want whatever
your purpose is you don't have a right
to force somebody else to teach you free
right commodity okay let's go to
Internet we just had Thomas Haslett to
talk about net neutrality so this one
seems to be confusing to people let's go
through a medial you have the right sure
with the Internet to be unimpeded and
the purchase of Internet access and I
would even say including protection from
dishonest inhibitory actions from
Internet service provider good thing is
those are already protected yeah and I
we have these with monopoly laws in the
government right now so that would be
your right to go get the internet that
you want the internet plan that you want
that is your right what's a commodity
the internet or broadband access
packages themselves now a key term
anecca now it's excludable that means
non paying consumers can't access it and
rival risk means that additional
consumers increased the cost
significantly that's when that
neutrality matters these terms
excludable rivals tend to reoccur when
it comes to dealing with commodities man
okay HBO for free
yeah you don't get on there for free you
don't get HBO go for free is everyone
tracking any question I'm tracking
pretty clear contraceptives this is a
new one contraceptive that's right right
it's a human right contraceptives okay
well let's even go with this you have
the right to access and purchase any
contraceptives of your choosing I'll
agree no one should bar you from buying
one buying a rubber and a truckstop or
an IUD I don't care or just rewrite it
what's a commodity the contraceptive
birth control pills condoms IUDs they
don't just fall out of the sky someone
invented them often a man so this is the
right protects your ability to pursue
something a right almost never
guarantees or forces somebody else to
provide you with something yes that's
important and we've gotten off of
beaming with contraceptives well that's
only the extreme leftist social justice
warrior so okay let's go to one that see
almost everyone seems on board with
water people that should be the most
basic human right is water okay sure
you're right what is your right to have
the right to consume or utilize any non
privately owned water I don't think
anyone should be barred from accessing
water the Antelope can go get water he
risks being torn apart by a lion and
that makes for great TV but it's his
right now what would be a commodity oh
maybe water itself if it's filtered
sanitized pumped directly into your
place of dwelling through an intricate
system of pipes and technology it didn't
happen for free you have the right to
water you don't have the right to force
somebody to pay to clean and sanitize
your water do we understand this here's
something it's a fundamental this is
what I wanted to wrap up with a
fundamental difference in world
people know if you're an ideologue it
matters because everyone has some kind
of a lens through which they see the
world
the ISM matters and if you look at
actually on the flip side rights that
conservatism fights for rights that
right now
conservatives are fighting for most
actively I think it would probably agree
conservatives when you're talking about
rights they're most actively fighting
right now for probably probably freedom
of speech and guns yeah those are two
big issues protection of life I would
say yeah production of light yeah okay
yeah so let's start with freedom of
speech
all right so conservatives are actively
fighting for that right well okay first
off how do you know what's your right
where is that proscribed up amendment
number one right freedom of speech in
the Constitution it actually talks about
free speech now here's something to
that's important to note when
conservatives fight for freedom of
speech
even if you see the controversy with
YouTube having censored some of our
content or Facebook you'll see a lot of
conservatives say they actually have the
right to do that and we agree with that
they just don't have the right to lie to
consumers about it bad business
practices that's a different issue but
conservatives understand that we have
the right to speak freely and are
fighting it's a right that the left
doesn't believe in they don't believe in
it professors don't believe it now I'm
not just talking about in specific areas
or instances they don't believe in a
generalized absolute right to free
speech we do when we're fighting for it
we're fighting for the right to speak
freely fully understanding that we are
not going to be paid to speak freely
look at guns what we believe okay we
believe that we have the right to keep
and bear gut it's a right that liberals
don't believe it right so this is
important the fun straight stay with me
here we believe that we have the right
to own and keep guns well where'd you
get that from well it's amendment number
two so right now we're just going
through number one and two sweetheart
okay so there's at least we're making
the declarative statement we have the
right to keep and bear arms that's the
right we fight for in like freedom of
speech we're just fighting for the
ability to have them we're not
protesting Smith & Wesson to give us
free guns and that's a fundamental
difference in worldly because we look at
the rights that then liberals declare
that their rights healthcare education
water shelter basic universal income
right you say well how do you know those
are rights uh I will just file it all
under the general welfare clause it's
nowhere in the Constitution it's the
ones that we must strive are there by
name there's don't even exist but let's
even go with it okay you
the general welfare clause sure okay you
have the right to pursue health care of
course yeah yeah we believe in the right
to access to water sure you have the
right to purchase birth control no they
are taking rights that don't exist
filing them under a term that was not
meant for that and then fighting for the
right to force you and I to pay for it
through our tax dollars that is a
fundamental world--you difference the
rights that are outlined and prescribed
as per our legal documents they don't
even believe exist what about freedom of
speech it's hate speech what about the
Second Amendment roommates too much
money
oh so what you don't believe those are
rights no I think I should have a right
to 25 cent Robert a truck stop and you
should pay for it this is something that
matters so much because if you start off
from a point where you don't even
understand the difference between a
right or a commodity it just gets to you
were placed right with something I want
well then rights would be ever-changing
and guess what things that rights would
infringe on other rights because
everyone has different things that they
want right when I was a teenager I
wanted element fierson in my wall poster
to come to life but it wasn't my right
guess what her should feel like her
right 23 she should yes she should that
is important you can send some other
examples if you think that I'm wrong
rights versus economic commodities
anytime someone just says some things
are right they declare it call them on
it
well where do you find that and how do
you justify it most of the time they can
all right we'll be right back speaking
of this with Blair white
[Music]
and let's history shop and an alien look
back on the history of Germany and its
people but at this point million of
lives in Versailles in the violation of
human rights and every man woman and
child and Germany understood as a great
parable in the book of Hoffman said that
men can look at it
[Music]
[Music]
all right glad to have our next guest
return guests or to return guests
yesterday so you can follow well on
Twitter
miss Blair white and of course at miss
Blair what I need to say at I don't know
if when you use the @ anymore and then I
think it's assumed YouTube is it miss
Blair white ex Blair on YouTube
no just Blair white layer white X
Edwards singer give me some more juice
so I can hear Blair I don't know what
his deal is over there how are you doing
this is obviously a time where all this
exploded we had you booked before the
the whole military trends deal and and
here you are yeah it's been crazy if
there's lots of meltdowns lots of people
with a lot of different opinions I have
mixed opinions I woke up to it and of
course every social media I have was
just blowing up media requests like talk
about this talk about this and like I
said my feelings are a bit mixed I can
totally understand how generators phoria
would be something that would greatly
affect performance but I also think you
know on the other hand who am I like
this prissy [ __ ] in California to tell
anyone that if they like pass the
requirements and like go through the
psych evaluations basic training
whatever it is that you guys do cuz I'm
not a military expert Who am I to sit
here like in this apartment in LA and be
like you can't fight for me I don't know
it's mixed feelings right I understand I
think that's actually a pretty balanced
approach but hey you don't let's bounce
back to that because he used the word
meltdown I thought perfect segue
meltdown we were originally blocking you
to talk about this your debate on
YouTube with Onishi Anaka do do we have
this clip right quick clip alright did
you or did you not have like photos of
underage girls
to put in your videos to rate or to call
fat or skinny or acne any of that did
you did you not let me look up the
definition of collects do you really
just say that yes for that so I will say
this is probably the best most
convincing transgender argument to
people who aren't in the know I would
say because no straight sis male can get
that [ __ ] that was unbelievable
so you turned him into a high school
pegboard it was so if you haven't seen
it oh it was so I will tell you this
I've seen you you know have real
well kind of like I know you don't like
this guy because it devolved pretty
quickly he wasn't answering questions
like you clearly are not buddies with
Onishi on right no no and you know the
thing is like in the title of the video
I put a in quotation marks because I
knew it wasn't gonna be some formal like
Pleasant you know debate or any type of
like real substance to I knew it was
gonna be me like just talking to an easy
on it was a lot of fun what we are
because this prissy [ __ ] in California
and you're debating this I don't know
pseudo emo social justice warrior
liberal who is telling you that you're
intolerant it's like what what what what
cosmic wormhole did I fall into I think
people feel that when they're watching
this the roles have reversed so much
it's hard to make sense of right and
what happens so often with these male
feminists is they're so contradictory
because if you look at any Seon in
particular his behavior the way he's
treated women and underage girls is
absolutely just like act like it's
horrible
like he's made videos grading bodies of
like 12 year old girls and sports bras
it's horrible so it's just totally
contradictory
yeah I know and he went after me for
being a chauvinist because I wrote about
how my wife and I didn't have sex until
we were married you rape 12 year olds
yeah the definition of chauvinist I know
I know it is okay we'll go back to trans
in the military just for people haven't
seen it's very entertaining and I've
seen Blair have conversations that are
productive and that are I would say more
this probably wasn't that but I think
you'd probably yes but it was it was
entertaining because this is a guy it
was entertainment yes
it was entertaining okay so military
issue the trans issue we were talking
about this a little bit off there I've
always been against women in the front
lines in combat roles I've been against
the idea of lowering standards period
whether you're male or female and we
have we've lowered physical training
requirements we've lowered leg pull up I
mean just as simple as pull-ups or
push-ups I don't think we should be
doing that we've also lowered the
threshold for what drill sergeants can
do with with new recruits in the
military because people can be
traumatized that's become a much more
politically correct environment so I
think my issue here and what I don't
think Trump handled
well the way it was just kind of rolled
out general blanket statement but as
someone who very very possibly wouldn't
pass the psych evaluation to go into the
military I would say that's you know
that's very similar not passing the PT
requirements isn't would we agree
there's some validity here too obviously
there is some emotional volatility with
the trans community or psych psychiatric
volatility and and that needs to be
shielded from the military on those
grounds um I would say yes and no I
think that what needs to happen is
people need to be evaluated individually
because there are people who stay they
transitioned earlier and they don't have
any generators for yur really at all
left it really should be individual
case-by-case basis but I and so I do
agree that the way it was handled like
the blanket statement is weird and
immediately when this happened um my
mind didn't go to like future trans
people and adjoining village area went
Sheila people who've already there yeah
it went to the number it's so hard
getting numbers on people it's sorry but
I think the estimate was like seven
thousand eight thousand currently
enlisted and so that's a lot of
individuals that I'm concerned about
like losing their pensions losing their
job their GI Bill right that's where my
mind went and that currently is like
unclear if that's going to happen that's
true and that's a valid point I think
that's a real problem with basically you
know when I I would entertain the troops
and they they weren't allowed to speak
on the record but Barack Obama the
social justice warrior in chief turned
the military for the first time into a
social justice sort of petri dish in
experiment whereas the military was
always supposed to be devoid of that for
a long time and so he rushed things
quickly that maybe they weren't
necessarily ready for and now like you
said it's like on a second we've we've
run into some issues uh something we
were talking about obviously we've
talked about this in the show that the
trans suicide rate being higher um well
there is an issue not gay Jared brought
this up that someone in the military
right as it happens my dearest son
ironically CNN released a study right
alongside the the announcement of Trump
in the transgender military saying a
suicide attempt in an army unit can lead
to more study finds basically it says
hey if there's if one even post-service
retired soldiers if one of those people
in the unit commit suicide there's a
very very high chance of other people
from that division
not be able to cope with that right also
committing suicide so if we're taking
people I'll let you make the point but
it's if we're taking people who are from
sis population have these problems I can
only imagine gets much worse we have the
transgender population and that's why
psych evaluations are frequent and I
think that would be like a valid
conversation to have but that's not how
it was brought up by you know the
president and it just devolved quickly
yeah and the problem I think you talked
about this on your show before the word
transgender has just been so inflated
that it includes so many things and so
the problem is when you use the word now
you kind of also are talking about
people who don't have a formal diagnosis
or gender dysphoria right and so a lot
of these people being kept out could
very well be completely stable
individuals so it's yeah it's so messy
and it's so hard and confusing yeah I
think honestly people wouldn't have
nearly as big of an issue if it weren't
for sorry Jared sensor button if it
weren't for the social justice warrior
bulge that comes along with it listen
the last I mean you know having a
conversation with Tony Sheehan is
exhausting right we can have a
conversation and it's fun there's some
levity we can have some disagreements we
can agree but having a conversation with
a social justice warrior who's all about
pronouns and LGBTQ is exhausting put
them on the front lines people don't
need that at the front of their mind I
think that's the big issue now is
because the trans people that the people
in a trans community who are foolish
screaming the loudest absolutely and
that's the part that I struggle with and
maybe you do as well it's like trying to
decipher if it's really the majority of
them or if it's just we're so involved
in these conversations on the internet
that it really seems that way cuz when I
think about it I have met most trans
people I've met disagree with most if
not all of like the crazy activists
e-stop and that gives me hope and in
fact um interesting story the first
trans president ever met and who kind of
helped me find my way it was actually an
ex-marine
and it was a transgender man and he
started for a very long time and he was
like the most badass person I ever knew
most like amazing person I've ever met
and so that's another part I mean it's
like well it's so hard to say like you
can't do it you can't it's like there's
so much of it is arbitrary is the
problem so much of it is arbitrary
because you think like what if they're
not on hormones what if they are what if
they don't have this for it it's so
hard yeah well then that's where a
disagreement we had where if people
watch contextual II might interview with
a psychiatrist where I said you know
today's trans have more in common with
transvestites of Europe like that was
really insensitive sanjuana second I was
talking with a psychiatrist talking
about how they have to label anyone he s
on a dress and says I'm trans that skews
the statistics because they have to
label it that way and I said well what's
difference mean that in a transvestite
she said well nothing but they're all a
stress exam in umbrella and I'm like he
said that's why it's so hard to get
numbers okay moving on with this to talk
about this we were just talking about
this clip from the view and this is a
great example where the black
progressive realizes she's not super
progressive she's like okay so this
woman is the woman identifies by the way
is pansexual homo-romantic and
everyone's not like yeah and everyone
says yeah we understand it this is no no
you know people in the trans community
don't resent this just made up as we go
along and as she gets corrected by
someone on the view she says it's not
she it's they the black lady says well
but but they used men and women that's
because it's the only way she can
describe her preferences then someone
turn to her and say it's not she they
could you imagine this out there on the
battlefield like that's I think the
issue people are concerned with right I
will say though I highly doubt those
people are getting in and like passing
any type of service I will say that like
a five-year survival
they wouldn't a while ago but this it's
getting more now I mean you you lower
requirements you keep lowering them and
you politicize and military now that's
like a lot of people want to go in
sometimes to prove a point I do think
it's a good point you the people who are
in now they shouldn't lose their pinch
and they shouldn't you know if they're a
part of that they shouldn't be yeah be
screwed and left out in the cold because
of sure some political football yes that
does concern me because it's like
regardless of how anyone feels about
anyone's lifestyle or whatever like I'm
sure there's plenty of people in the
military whose lifestyles I don't agree
with maybe if they're like some I don't
know yeah I still are like red-blooded
Americans who put their lives on the
line and potentially are willing to make
like the ultimate sacrifice giving up
their lives for their country so the
idea of them losing their benefits and
everything that they deserve is is
troublesome to me that's really the
and that is that is pretty crappy I do
think yeah and you're able to often
discuss this and recognizes especially
in the military it really is about the
health of the unit so that's where how
the unit functions does matter and
that's why some people who doesn't mean
they're bad people
doesn't mean that they shouldn't be
allowed in other realms of society are
not an effective part of military unit a
lot of things people understand about
the military with women on the retreat
rates are higher because women on the
front lines with men men typically went
to war to protect women right to protect
the ovulate errs and now you put them on
the battlefield so the unit becomes very
protective of the woman and acts in a
way we as men are not as effectively
violent with women present that's a huge
factor and I think it's not just trans
now it's we're talking us with the view
trans and genderqueer if you say okay
trans like you said you're male to
female find a male restrooms but yet
people go in who don't want that they go
in the hon I'm actually fluid and
genderqueer well that matters when the
rest of the unit is going come on we
don't know the rules here Sarge I mean I
just want to be able to take a dump
without being watched by this person
who's a lesbian today and straight
tomorrow and the word transsexual still
actually means something very specific
right the word transgender is so
inflated and you and I are right there
with like women on the front lines as
well but good news is I can't be drafted
now so thank God legal change yeah thank
God
yeah well thank you thank God for
unequal rights jeez think about that
that's one of the things it's just when
women talk about certain things they
don't have or what now it's even sillier
when like gosh I had a guy open the door
for me I had someone cat calling like
guess what okay we die were the first
ones who are literally called against
our will to die and end case ok there's
some give and take I get shot up there's
give and take and it's like honestly
this brings you back to my old like MRA
days and I was like 18 but it's like men
have every disadvantage in women have
like none it's kind of crazy actually
even you really think about it
especially legally you know what I mean
like more prison time for the same crime
etc yeah and then prison time is a
distinctly less pleasant for men
when we go to prison um right it's not
orange is the new black no it's not
there's no law or pre pon let me ask you
so what would how would you ideally see
this scenario play out because we've
seen the outrage there on both sides how
would this ideally move forward do you
think in a where that's that's fair but
also conducive toward you know the most
effective fighting force on earth I
think just it's so hard to say because
like I know people with like severe acne
can't even join the military because
that like has other side effects like
psychologically yeah which is crazy but
I think that individuals should just be
screened individually I think that if
you can pass the test you can fight
however what are your thoughts on trans
people serving in other capacities
because to me it seems like well damn
you can't even be like a cook in the
canteen ian's or you can't even be like
a nurse you know what I mean what are
your thoughts on that gays make some
great coffee in dishes yes yes yeah I
would I would tend to say in that point
I have no problem with with women doing
those jobs as well so I think it's a
discussion that I think still needs to
be entertained because again of the
dynamic of a unit and I do think that
with the military it comes down to
purely a numbers game in other words if
this makes this unit 12% less effective
at fighting I think it's totally fine to
be discriminatory in the military in
those capacities because these people
are going out to die so but all you said
it's hard to find those numbers that
being said I'm fine with a woman doing a
job in the military that she can do as
well or better than a man
we just know that's not fighting at the
front lines so that would tend to be my
position on it but I wouldn't eat we
would need to see this is why the
military is not meant to be a social
experiment yes the only goal of it is to
kill people as effectively as possible
whatever does that to me is the most
important role of the military right
yeah I guess everyone's just so focused
on like the the combat part and then
kind of thinking like well what about
other positions but I mean it is all
about you know a fact of this but I
think you're right I don't think the
president thought that through before
the announcement that's the issue I
think was too blanketed and it didn't
allow for a conversation that should
happen no and it kind of sucks because
like I'm a trump supporter and I voted
for Trump so I'm like I'm more willing
to like give him the benefit of the
doubt and like look into things past
just the tweets but it sucks
like the rest of the country just sees
tweets and they don't really look
further and it becomes like more
ammunition against him and it's not been
the great the greatest week for him with
Jeff Sessions and stuff because there's
only so much you can be like hey this
guy's great then your supporters go hey
this guy's great like this guy sucks
it's like well hold on a second okay
it's tough it's tough to keep track I
you know even if you dig a little
further he wasn't super clear on this
and yeah I think it's important to know
exactly where he stands what the policy
is so that the people can know if they
actually agree with it or disagree with
it and then certainly for people that
view and myself so that then we can at
least argue one side that's definitive I
don't think that's the case no we don't
know that every policy you can't down
two hundred forty characters on Twitter
right yeah that's the thing you can't
really argue super strongly for or
against it because it's like well what
happens people that are there what
happens with this like it's all very
arbitrary and a lot of it's still not
out yet so so it sounds like would you
be advocating I guess at least if you we
were to say blanketed more concrete
meaning okay someone needs to have gone
through these stages of transitions so
we can identify them and know where to
put them as opposed to gender fluidity
you know in the military yeah because I
mean there are a lot of documentaries
about trans people in the military and
and most of them are honestly like trans
men who are like on testosterone and
like they've completely transitioned and
like they're just kind of badasses and
it's kind of cool to watch actually
sometimes they strangle ben shapiro live
on air yeah nothing was feminine zillion
threatening violence god I'm still not
over that video I still watch it
sometimes I just go back to them like
wow that's like horrible I don't know I
mean this is tragic yeah but yeah wait
again I just think individual screenings
would be better because and the gender
fluid definitely I think should just be
kept out because you do need a binary
you do need to know where to put people
and if you make it complicated like you
just stay the [ __ ] out it's not the
place for you right it's not like I said
it's not a social experiment well
especially if we're also gonna talk
about you know you have liberals coming
out when it's convenient talk about rape
culture in the military it's like okay
well listen you have a bunch of people
who are going out to war who just killed
folks right saw a pink mist and they're
coming back and they're amped up and
then you put a woman in their barracks
and they're in their shower and again
that's a problem and so it's the same
thing when it
to the transition we need to know where
to put them because again effective
fighting military unit you can't just
have someone who's gender-fluid who goes
wherever they want on any given day
because then you're encouraging
quote-unquote rape culture which by the
way is not nearly as tall in the
military as the media's made it out to
be it's been a it's been a right it asks
right it absolutely has to be binary if
trans people are gonna be there it has
to be completely binary it can't be um
gray area as in questions because that's
just a mess
sounds like hate speech to me miss Blair
white where is the best place for for
people to find you here we have to get
going
youtube.com slash Blair White X and my
twitter is twitter.com slash MS Blair
way Thank You well thanks so much for
coming on it just happened to be I guess
providential is just we were going to
talk about Arnie Sheehan and instead we
talked about the most topical issue of
the day miss Blair white we will have
you back soon we have to go with Alex
Epstein
Emily nice
[Music]
eat it
David Josephine to my washing louder was
proper is it 9:00 p.m. Eastern always
day there's Bernie like free she is the
sunrise in the east of course I watch it
louder with brighter you know I never
miss it
you're obsessed Colton it's not healthy
yeah would you know about health miss
forklift with teeth just a stupid Shoko
I don't care about you give me one with
that no you back to last race in the pit
row and you know it take a look right
there boom from everybody I'm down with
the verified chip more don't wanna hear
any more turbo / you know it's not a
real sound guy it's just the character
he plays do you know it's that kind of
stupid showed you telling her you are
josephine he is a legitimate qualified
sound technician from a traceability
shallow damn burger but with sour
related appliances your fingers work too
fat to operate a try-catch or maybe even
try it who wants to lie you know better
to work that Jarrod's not even gay I've
had with your lies josephine in back of
me show you when I'm quoting scripture
from our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
maybe even put down your show bags every
once in a while for a hot minute you
know better
[Music]
there you are it's live Reid time which
usually happens about once a week maybe
you're listening on iTunes or SoundCloud
a lot happened this week a lot happened
and that's the beauty of The Daily Show
which you get the show once a week for
free and you get clips but you don't see
the full Daily Show that's for mug club
members only a lot of its $99 annually
69 for students veterans active military
here's the deal listen it keeps everyone
employed here it allows us to not be
beholden to the YouTube and Facebook
overlords but you know what it is you
know where to find it if at this point
you watch Kimmel Conan Fallon Trevor
Noah
Samantha bee Seth my all-of-the-above
ABC NBC CBS and you don't see the need
for any alternatives out there then
there is no convincing you if you want
to see not gauge yard and sound guy
Edward and everyone else involved with
the program who puts out the daily
content not destitute and out in the
street and you understand the value in
an alternative to all the late-night
entertainment shows go ahead and join
yourself
[Music]
[Music]
all right glad to have our next guest
love dammit he's been on the show before
so it's kind of like we always say that
when people return his guests it's sort
of excites like Carson bringing someone
over the couch except we are not
successful like Jefferson that was a
horrible comparison but the origin story
is over often with superhero films the
origin story it's like you cannot to
introduce the audience a collation so
they have to kind of explain what
they're about his book the moral case
for fossil fuels you can follow him on
Twitter don't call him Stein Alex
Epstein how are you sure it's actually
totally wrong is it gonna get it it's
time but I definitely don't care well I
know but others have reverencing Young
Frankenstein but well you know it looks
like number two is the final visit for
Alex every time it's okay it's not
foolproof anyways I've been on this
program forever still can't blame lies
suck it yeah yeah we still can't explain
it listen so we wanted to have you on it
was it was actually toss-up between you
or my father because the Detroit film is
coming out and and that's also likely a
bowl excrement but Al Gore's An
Inconvenient Truth too is out now did
you get like a screener of this because
it seems that you've already seen the
film correct yeah yeah I used a lot of
fossil fuels to get to this take a lot
cuz I'm in San Francisco now which of
course I had to use fossil peels to get
there from the DC area where I grew up
but but even in the near term I had to
go from San Francisco to LA and back in
the same day which is a miracle of
petroleum yes in order to see this
quote-unquote documentary because I
wanted to be able to credibly comment on
it in advance and particularly to write
a review of it so yeah I'm fully
qualified I I managed to finagle my way
into a screening full of people who were
not wearing I love fossil closer well
you know what listen it's actually
pretty easy if Al Gore is attending the
screening with I would imagine with a
red-carpet premiere just walk up to him
wearing open-toed shoes you're golden
you're into the premiere right away so
let me ask you this we've had ad
McIlhenny on the show specifically
because she did not evil just wrong
where she went through a few key
predictions from Inconvenient Truth the
first one that were verifiably false
right I mean to the point where it's
embarrassing
where does our gore go from there well
what can we expect to see in this movie
how does he turn that around it's
interesting because he one of his
prominent quote unquote predictions was
that there would be 20-foot sea level
rises now he didn't specify the exact
timetable but we were led to believe
that it would be several decades and
even if you look at the UN which I think
relies heavily on climate prediction
models that can't predict climate even
they say things like two feet right
right so in what Gore has this ingenious
thing sort of where he starts out and he
quotes a chorus of people whom he later
explains to us are either fools or
shills from the fossil fuel industry and
they are ridiculing Gore and one of the
things they say is that oh you said sea
levels of rise 20 feet and I perked up
and I thought wow how is he gonna get
out of this one bigger they definitely
didn't definitely aren't right and what
he did is he just he doesn't brought up
this chorus to bring for this idea that
since An Inconvenient Truth Al Gore has
been victimized by fools and shills
that's premise number one right of the
movie who claimed that he over predicted
these things well first off even if that
were true it still doesn't answer the
20-feet question but I'm tracking wrote
oh but he's he's sort of he's making it
seem like he's going to and then he he
says then kind of premise 2 is long on
the renewables replacing fossil fuels
issue that's totally happened I'm gonna
gives a whole bunch of anecdotes which
is distinct from data yes he gives a
whole bunch of anecdotes allegedly
proving that and then he gives a whole
bunch of anecdotes proving climate has
gotten worse but he never quite
addresses the 20-foot thing and then you
step back and you think wait but he
never actually proved any of these are
trends he just gave us anecdotes that
make us think that the trends exist
and fortunately professionally I studied
the trend so I know the trend so is just
it was I found just in critters not evil
just wrong but you know it's it's really
evil to manipulate data to make a trend
seem like the opposite of what it is and
I can elaborate but the trends of in
terms of how vital fossil fuels are and
how safe we are from climate are the
exact opposite of what this manipulative
movie says that one second knock eaters
gonna
heart attack why are you laughing so
hard it's like a really bad episode a
typical episode of Alaska state trooper
we're about your cool stuff really cool
stuff almost happens what did you so he
put a few predictions obviously the seer
eyes okay doesn't like that's answered
what about the catastrophic draught and
then of course another one was this this
proliferation of of disease and natural
disasters did he address did he address
did he address any of those specifics
because you know a part of me did think
with the first Inconvenient Truth like
hey this is kind of ballsy to put out
predictions that you can be called on
but not if you just don't actually
answer people calling you on it I think
there's a great lesson in the movie
because it feels like he's addressing
them because he gives you anecdotes that
if those anecdotes were generally the
case would vindicate him and you don't
know in the movie that those anecdotes
aren't generally okay so let's take
let's just take severe drought okay
something like that so I'll show a
drought in Syria then he makes a whole
bunch of bogus foreign policy
connections but we'll leave that aside
so what you're led to think is Oh
drought related deaths are getting worse
right more people are dying from drought
people and this is actually untrue
completely untrue drought related deaths
in the last eighty years are down 99.98%
yeah they're virtually non-existence
thanks to what thanks to industrial
development that turns you know droughts
in - not a problem yeah so this is just
a complete misrepresentation and if we
took away from spousal fuels droughts
would become a huge problem again
because we would develop right what
about like Ebola and Zika that seems
like it's the result of global warming
climate change I mean this is I talked a
little bit about the history of some of
these in moral case for fossil fuels
because they act like oh these things
have never crossed any borders before
and malaria is a disease of just the
cold and historically these aren't true
we have records showing people dying of
these things all over the place and
guess what when you have more travel
you're gonna have potentially more
transferring of these things so again
your friend is industrial development
that's what keeps us safe that's what
allows us to make progress so the idea
that we should de energize our society
strictly
most fossil fuels and then disease will
get better that's the opposite disease
deaths are on the decline but only as
long as we continue industrial
development well what if they say okay
we understand that that disease or is on
a decline or deaths are are lowered now
because of technology with drought but
it's a ticking time bomb we can only do
this for so long before we run out of
resources hence you know I know Al Gore
makes a strong well Al Gore makes a
passionate argument for replacing
everything with wind or solar now we've
talked about in our program Germany and
having to sell off energy at net
negative prices because solar is so
unreliable than having energy droughts
themselves but if he says okay yeah
technical technology the Industrial
Revolution has led us out for example we
have cures for polio you know you don't
need to worry about tuberculosis but now
we're at a point where we're running out
of resources it seems that he could make
that case does he well no he definitely
doesn't make that case it's interesting
with fossil fuels that people have two
arguments one is that we're using too
much and one is that we won't have
enough right which is a little bit of a
contradiction right because nature would
take care of the problem if we were
running out and they should be happy so
what you can tell us you're just always
finding a way to oppose fossil fuels
without any kind of coherent narrative
and right now because of the amazing
technological achievements of the oil
and gas industry with shale energy that
whole Peak Oil narrative is out the
window at least for a decade or two so
now they're just back to do you better
seat sure a lot of us who are younger
don't even know that that was the term
Peak Oil oil cover of a cover of time it
was on that I was like seemed like every
other every other day there was
something on the the NatGeo channel you
know or Discovery Channel about Peak Oil
or do they fear mongering GOP I haven't
heard Peak Oil in years
Alex yeah yeah I mean I I was still
writing I was writing about oil when I
was ridiculed for believing that Peak
Oil was bogus really if you understand
economics this whole issue of depletion
and replacement is just what the whole
question is what's the best form of
energy right now and in the foreseeable
future and we have this amazing thing
called freedom and a market which allows
us to decide that and then if we start
to run low on something or if the price
goes up then we start to replace it but
Gore is not an advocate of superior play
because he's against nuclear power he's
against hydropower he's against fracking
he's in favor of inferior replacements
the so-called solar and wind renewables
which are properly called unreliable
it's properly going reliable
you know it's funny because that just
shows us how some issues are politicized
specifically with the national borders
an example we use was this idea of
suppressor silencers on guns you know in
the United States they're opposed by the
anti-gun lobbyists because they say you
know everyone's gonna be an assassin
everyone's gonna be a Corleone a going
around killing people in their face
falling in spaghetti and meatballs
whereas in the UK where they have much
more stringent gun laws it's considered
rude in many parts to not hunt with a
suppressor it's funny mention hydropower
I'm from Quebec a socialist province of
Quebec where there is no conservative
right there's liberal liberal separatist
they're on board with every single piece
of climate change legislation that
exists our electric bills people always
said you're hydro bill I remember when
people would visit it's a hydro bill
your water bill we'd say no no electric
because it's almost all hydroelectric
power in Quebec so I guess I wasn't even
aware of this until the last few months
that's been politicized where that's
considered not green enough oh yeah yeah
now why is that because again we've been
doing that for a like it seemed that it
couldn't get more renewable than using
the energy of running falling water
right so the idea of green is to
minimize impact on nature if you really
want to minimize impact on nature then
you really just shouldn't do anything we
should have never built New York City
you should never have a child and many
scientists where is Excel any part and
you know North Korea is a much better
country than South Korea because they've
done very little impacting of nature so
they haven't read any blowing up phone
so I'll give that's one for North Korea
so if you look at you made me lose my
train of thought those hydro if you look
at hydro they'll say well look we can't
dam a river and then they look at
nuclear we can't split an atom and you
say wait a second isn't co2 supposed to
be the catastrophe of the century you're
not willing to dam a river to stave off
the catastrophe of the center you're not
willing to risk a meltdown to stave off
thing and what you find is that no
because they're the environmentalism is
as always
supported one form of energy in its
entire history and that is imaginary
energy they only support sources that
don't work as long as they don't work
because every source of energy has a
major impact so as soon as solar becomes
practical they'll say oh my gosh it's
destroying our countryside we can't
allow that
yeah well that's also that's also a
great point even think about again cuz
hydropower was electric power where we
were now back particularly on the south
shore of Montreal it's a great indicator
of if we did have these catastrophic
floods the 20 levels see rise that
they're not gonna come to humans aid
it's like hey there's a sea rice
can we dam this no no there's some
there's rainbow trout now what are you
out of your mind get the hell out of
here alright okay Alex we have to get
going will have you back hopefully if
there's a hope we'll see if there's some
followed honestly I haven't really seen
a whole lot of buzz for An Inconvenient
Truth it's because I do not do not watch
it by the way the people who are
screening it said they asked Al Gore how
they could help he said screen my movie
which isn't really but because we want
as many people to watch it as possible
so please do not watch it is a really
bad movie by a bad person I won't say
pirate it but but that's one thing you
can do to help the world the only thing
I've heard you haven't seen it because
the promotional material and budget
really has gone into 2031 when they're
releasing and giving it true 3 yes yes
yeah and he's spending a lot of time on
the board at Apple Al Gore has his
interests or split these days all right
Alex Epstein the moral case for fossil
fuels you can read it you can find it I
highly recommend it sharp man Alex we'll
have to have you back soon with some
follow-up on this all right good to be
here thanks to you thank you by the back
[Music]
viewer discretion is advised
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Dominus cops is filmed on location with
the brave strong women of law
enforcement
all suspects are innocent until proven
guilty in a court of law
one officer down on corner shut the main
to posting backup going to perform a
tactical reload
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright thanks to Alex Epps Time Stein
get it wrong as a good way to get in the
good graces of a host correct him first
thing off the bat do you realize
honestly I nobody takes a bigger
steaming a fecal pile on our show than
us something I find funny is when you
look at people actually the way they
attack our show and our joke writing or
dressing us dressing as women they're
taking insults that we wrote against
ourselves with the hit exactly it's like
we wrote this any time you see a bit
where I'm getting insulted or hurt or
embarrassed I wrote it yeah half the
time when you see me doing really
embarrassing stuff for some demented
idea I came I wrote that do you wrote it
no that was that was that was a non
sequitur but if you'd have corrected
Bill O'Reilly first you're gone that's
true
yeah thing with Bill O'Reilly like it's
okay we can't I remember Bill O'Reilly
it was well known if you didn't mic him
in 15 seconds you didn't work for Bill
O'Reilly that's okay Jeff it's John oh
yeah you're gone you're gone
it's Epstein you're fired thanks so much
to Blaire white Alex Epstein we are
going to not is it Monday we're missing
Monday we'll be missing Tuesday we'll be
back with our Hawaii special that's
right we'll be back with the Hawaii
special on Tuesday for mug Club members
because we have some work that bleed or
not some work to do in Hawaii I would
actually take a home occasion at this
point if I could have been traveling too
much staycations most trendy or name
staycation that's the turn is that
actually the term that's actually the
term yeah staycation yeah you just
couldn't afford a trip for some of them
oh speaking of cruelty so this is
something you know people were talking
about the Jordan Peterson test and I
scored off the charts and compassion but
not so much in politeness which I
think's some people may have been
surprised I don't think people who are
who are mug Club members who watch the
show with any great regularity you know
this I you know I hate to ever bully
people and that's why we never take pot
shots like The Young Turks are like the
left without offering them recourse if
we go after someone if we attack
somebody and they say hey that's not
correct we want to come on the show and
we'll always allow them that platform
doesn't mean everybody's allowed this
platform at any time because you have
two followers and an egg avatar but some
of these channels like Young Turks have
made an entire career entire platform
off of punching down yes it's their
thing well punching and then just okay
well let's talk about it No
and that was kind of Onishi until till
blair white you know for long a blur I
was a tiny Channel and then he wanted to
bait her when she was a bigger Channel
when Blair was a bigger Channel I know
I'm getting just stop with the pronouns
people are always gonna try and trip me
up no matter what it was
Blair um so here's something that's
important to note and I was talking with
Owen Benjamin about this I always hated
it was really hard for me to get along
with people in the entertainment
industry because of how jackass ish they
were because of how left us an elitist
they were and then I always felt really
pretty lonely with conservatives because
of how when I was at Fox News for four
and a half years because it wasn't
necessarily a very creative environment
it was a numbers game and I didn't
relate to them a whole bunch now um the
reason I disliked the left when I was in
entertainment was because they were
bullies I learned pretty early on being
dropped from management for making fun
event picked the liberal causes or
whether it was being banned from a from
a college or getting calls to my
management for making a Mohammed joke at
the University cultural fair week our
cultural appreciation fair week I don't
know what it was but I had these run-ins
pretty early on that being said I was
bullied a lot I think a lot of people
here were bullied a lots of kid
I know Owen and I were talking about
most comedians were bullied a lot of
kids most creative types were bullied a
lot had pretty miserable childhoods
which is why I hate this narrative
that's put out there now that the LGBTQ
AIP are the only people who are bullied
and I think that's where some people may
be mistaken as a lack of compassion I
was talking with Jordan Pederson about
this
my first instinct honestly you know what
the chanc Weger thing when I went when I
hijacked his stage I felt bad about that
I was like maybe we shouldn't upload
this because we plan on making a joke
out of it but then when there were so
few people in the audience you know I
thought I said like you could pick a
show of mine in anywhere USA that wasn't
well promoted and it could look really
bad I don't want to do that and like
yeah but then he tossed to the audience
to make fun of you and the guy refused
to debate so I kind of had to I don't
plan on ever doing that again just so
you know um but even there I felt bad
and my first instinct when I see people
like you see on the view the Little Miss
American History X Little Miss room it's
an ironic nickname I feel bad
my heart goes out to them because I'm
you know okay I can see you were
probably a misfit at some point you
probably weren't treated very well and I
see how that would shape your worldview
so some people they still feel bad
because they just look at someone and
saying oh they're fat oh they're ugly
it's the way that therefore it's mean to
pick on them because naturally you're
being the bully but they fail to realize
that they're watching an entire panel of
people on broadcast television who 100%
agree with each other
Whoopie well Jeb did what's named a joy
behar the the blonde woman there who was
hosting the panel and an entire panel of
people telling you what pronouns you can
use at some point we're adults so it's
not compassionate just to say well I
feel I feel bad for this person and
that's that's a trick that's often used
nowadays and sometimes it's happened
with us where we felt guilty like oh man
I've really this this person is kind of
a sorry character I don't want to go
after them then you must want a second
this person is actively trying to remove
the freedoms of other people this person
is actively trying to remove the freedom
of speech of other people this person
who just so happens to be a land whale
is actively trying to remove your
god-given right to self protection to
the Second Amendment and then you
realize hold on a second not only are
they trying personally but every single
person in the industry that up until
recently thanks to the internet
controlled the entire flow of
information are backing them up we are
now adults and if you got a swirlie when
you were younger you had someone call
you a name and I'm sorry if someone made
fun of you because you were gay or you
were trans that's not acceptable it
shouldn't be done on a basis that's
cruel
but now we're adults and just being
silent and being intimidated can't be
confused with compassion and the left
today this is what Owen talked about as
well they are the bully pulpit I wonder
if I was if I were born in a different
era if I would have probably gone after
maybe the the the Christian
conservatives here in the Brady Bunch
era I wonder if because everyone said
this is the way you have to be I've
naturally had a problem with authority
as seen in the personality assessment
test with Jordan Peterson where I would
have rejected that because they were the
bullies at one point any time some one
thing you have to be this way or when
conservatives or Christians were trying
to actively censor speech at one point I
would've been fighting against that but
we are in an era right now where the
bullying comes entirely from the left
and it does matter when you look at
leftism versus constitutionalism as we
talked about with rights before language
matters
rights versus commodities these things
matter facts matter statistics matter
what's going on in our country matters
not just how you feel for one person
time because that is what the left is
using right now they're trotting out
people that's what they're trotting out
just an absolute circus show of freaks
so that you hopefully stay sounds like
hey hey anyone want to criticize the
butch cutted chain-gang BuzzFeed lesbian
painting with their period blood with
the purple lipstick I didn't think so
they're being the bullies they're the
Corleone's who are saying uncle says
hello and rapping the piano wire around
your neck because you used the wrong
pronoun so don't let that happen that's
one thing too I see a lot of people
saying you know I try I just got an
email this week actually direct message
on Twitter saying you know people just I
don't want people to think that I'm this
this horrible per I don't want people to
think of em as this person with a
complete lack of compassion but I also
think that these things are I think men
and women are important I think that the
societal norms that have created the
bedrock of Western civilization and I
don't want to come across as a dick how
do you balance it the truth is we're at
a point where you can't you can't and it
doesn't matter because you will be seen
as the bully even though right now to
walk back up to the lgbtq a a IP to the
view to all of late-night all of
mainstream media all of the DNC You Tube
Facebook who helped helped a man get
killed will be killed in Pakistan for
blasphemy loss these people are the
bullies and you can't you can't balance
that with the perception of compassion
because the people who have set up the
bully pulpit and I've realized that this
week they have deliberately stacked the
cards against you so that if you speak
up at all you will automatically be
assumed guilty of a lack of Compassion's
at this point if you know your
compassion if you know that you care
about people no guilt don't feel guilty
speak truth and understand that today in
2017 doesn't matter who the president is
there is a bully pulpit the likes of
which we've never seen they're trying to
determine what you can say what you can
do and even what you can think and what
the rest of us can even think
collectively and I do want to see more
people going out there speaking truth
than trying to feign compassion don't
feel guilty about it because I did for a
long time and I rightfully admit that
was a byproduct of my
bringing so don't let it happen you
don't get caught in it they're gonna
vilify you anyway play the he'll see you
next week
[Music]